in the meantime Marjorie Taylor green is
becoming Donald Trump's latest attack
dog against Ron DeSantis yesterday I
told you about Kerry Lake going after
DeSantis in service of trump now it is
Marjorie Taylor green what Carrie Lake
and Marjorie Taylor green have in common
um is they both seem to be openly vying
to be Donald Trump's vice presidential
choices here's Marjorie Taylor green
also attacking DeSantis for where he is
announcing his campaign which he did
last night on Twitter spaces you don't
announce that you're running for
some kind of
kind of little real world Twitter is not
real so I can't comprehend why that
would be the place to do the
announcement it makes no sense it's not
serious okay so Marjorie Taylor green
says DeSantis isn't serious remember
that there are there is the belief that
Trump will pick a woman to be his
running mate this time around the four
women whose names are being floated are
Marjorie Taylor green Carrie Lake Nikki
Haley who's running against Trump and
Christy gnome from South Dakota who it's
not even clear if she's interested and
it's not even really clear if she's the
top Contender so arguably Marjorie
Taylor green participating in this in
service to supporting her own potential
candidacy to be Donald Trump's vice
president a wild 24 hours all of these
clips will be on our Instagram which you
can find by searching Instagram for
David packman show they'll be on our
Tick Tock and they will be on our
YouTube channel as well